[Music]
I'm Frank Hall I'm the project manager
for the x-ray project and
hewlett-packard we produced the XR live
user interface library which we've
contributed to project Athena I'll talk
a little bit about that and about what
the x-ray project is attempting to do
our commitment to standards and
sponsoring identifying and sponsoring
standards for user interface within the
industry there are a couple of handouts
one of them this is a short paper which
summarizes sort of what I'll say and a
copy of my slides are in the back there
is a an excerpt from our programmers
manual
it's called programming with the X
Window System this is a prototype of it
it's it's becoming a product and we will
be shipping supposedly first to February
if the shipping department is in line
this is an excerpt
it contains the table of contents from
the manual which shows you the the
second chapter is the XR libe I'm
choosing the X live documentation
standard from MIT unchanged and it just
goes through and shows you that the
basic structure of the manual what you
have here is the first chapter of the
manual that had that steps you through
for examples programming and X then a
little bit higher programming adding a
little bit of title bars pieces out of
the xx our live library moving you up
until it you have a simple hello world
program that has dialogue boxes and
menus and so forth and I'd if any of you
like to misspelled word so I would
suggest that you do it right and
misspell it in big bold letters on a
yellow cover
to pass it out to a bunch of people okay
okay
the let me let me tell you a little bit
about our background that'll be helpful
in understanding what is we're trying to
do
Hewlett Packard has a commitment to
standards and we also and that means
UNIX in the workstation market we are we
are committed to UNIX as a standard we
want to stimulate the software
development for UNIX workstations and we
feel that it's going slowly and we want
to stimulate that and get it moving
we we see the ms-dos world that has a
lot of advanced user interface software
we want to see that flowing into UNIX oh
you want to see a lot of it on UNIX more
of it on UNIX and ms-dos when I get it
going okay
how do we do that well let me start with
a quote from Dave Rosenthal now up son
this came in out in the UNIX review I
don't know if can you see that though
thank you
okay this is a this is a direct quote
does X offer the capabilities needed to
become a de facto standard he breaks it
up into three things that would be
needed the lowest generically describes
something like X on top of it there's a
user interface library that adds
components like menus and so forth and
you stick pieces together to you program
at that level by sticking pieces
together obviously this library should
be closely matched to the layer beneath
it such as X on top of that you want a
level that lets you generate user
interface easily we we had been before
we discovered X we had been thinking
along these very lines for about two
years gradually getting more and more of
a vision of where user interface needed
to go when we discovered X we loved it
we wanted to promote it as a standard we
asked ourselves what could we do
customers were telling us that we needed
to have a user interface library for
Hewlett Packard what were we planning to
do put pieces together and came up with
this X ray user interface library and
the way that we were instructed to
proceed I think is very telling in the
the need for UNIX to get user interface
standards going we started two years ago
we first were going to do a series of
advanced user interface UNIX
applications and discovered immediately
we needed a toolbox and would you take
your prototype application typically the
way tool boxes start you take your wizzy
application you say what can I take out
of this and turn it into a little
toolkit and we've seen some examples of
that this morning okay then you you say
well now I'm missing some features or
there's some rough edges I want to sort
of we are connect it you want to throw
it away come back do it right and then
if you proceed like we did somebody else
inside core the big corporation that
you're in says no wait a minute who are
you guys you know we have all this list
of credentials for user interface we're
going to do the right user interface you
guys you guys cancel your project just
wait six months will come out it'll be
great it'll be a standard new standard
so you get cancelled you sit around you
so you keep programming in the
background you know
and finally that those people are about
to come out with it and then somebody
says we know it's not object-oriented
you know that's the future and what we
really need is a standard is
object-oriented and who are you guys you
don't know about object-oriented program
and cancel your project so that gets
Kent we're sitting about programming in
the background where it would in you
know we were revived canceled revised
canceled and we were getting a little
tired of that and decided that if we
were given a chance we were going to
just go for it and we planted seeds in
people's minds that we knew what we
wanted to do we had a plan let us do it
and when a very big company came to HP
management and said you know you don't
have user interface library what are
your plans for them if you don't have
plans you can tell us then forget it
okay that got John Young's personal
attention he's the CEO of HP immediately
ramifications running down the chain of
command okay
we need fire up a user interface library
project immediately okay BAM we're back
in business
we've got okay okay all right okay so so
we're ready to go and the question was
what do you do and first we had to do a
lot of time figuring about what to do
with this level X came along that was
great we we changed our name to X ray we
saw what we had to do need to be closely
matched to X we wanted to to move on and
we gradually planted seeds that you know
X's in the public domain you know what
we should be doing should be in the
public domain and gradually that build
up and what we now are trying to do is
stimulate public domain standards for
user interface okay and X are live is
the first step in that we just show you
a little slide quickly those of you who
are trying to sell the concept of X and
client-server architecture you know how
hard that is to convey I suggest a slide
sort of like that this the only
significance of this for our talk is
that we use this to show how X ray fits
on top of X the application uses both X
and X ray they work together and that's
basically the
the way it all fits let me show you what
x-ray has our design focus was extant
ten
looking ahead to version 11 we wanted
okay our strategy is first to address
current customer needs we have very real
customer roots with very real needs they
want to be selling products they don't
have products on the market this year
they want they're going to be developing
now they're asking us for our next phase
and now it's we we simply can't wait for
a future standard we see that as another
example of possibly the leap frogging
that we've been encountering within HP
okay so we we are moving ahead towards a
standard but we want to start with the
dress and current customer needs it's
not the current customer is programming
in C right now standard languages
they're looking ahead towards objective
languages like C++ okay so we have to
have a plan for how to get there but our
first strategy is first to address the
current customer needs our research told
us that we did have an architecture that
allowed layout of arbitrary objects that
the user can sue add a thermometer or
whatever the user wants to add in these
interactive gadgets have to be done in a
way that a panel of them can accept new
ones just coming in and still operate on
them send them messages like make
yourself sensitive make yourself
insensitive without even knowing what
it's talking to okay so the architecture
that evolved is at the highest layer you
have the interactive dialogue components
like menus we provide pop-up cascading
or walking menus the items in the the
menu can have keyboard equivalents so
that for power users they can see their
menu they realize if I want to hit ctrl
B I'll get this function without popping
up the menu it allows you to serve both
initial users as well as power users
items in the menu cannot can force
direct functions or events to pop into
the X Q or execute functions directly
and the user has control over
configuring how they the
access to the menu is what button should
bring up the menu when the menu comes up
I'm I in a drag model or our a might use
the menu come up and then I go and
select and click again those things are
left to the user the purpose of x-ray
was not to to dictate a particular user
interface but allow people if they're
configuring a system to choose what what
fits for them okay message boxes this is
the dialog box we called it message box
because we didn't want to confuse the
dialog layer with a dialog box we went
for ease of programming like you can set
up a menu a simple menu just by
initializing a constant that has a set
of ASCII strings in it for your for your
menu items that's your data structure
that you need for the simplest menu very
easy to do similar for dialog box you
just and then you feed that that
structure into the call to create a
dialogue or a message box or a menu and
you've got it
panels are built up of field editors
arbitrary field editors which is what
we're calling these interactive gadgets
I'll explain that it operates as a whole
Hewlett Packard's work in user interface
for many years we've been active in it
it had been mainly based on terminals at
first we started out with soft keys and
made those important and we've been
working in block mode working in by
termina where the terminal takes over
moving you around the form so on what we
needed to do we felt was to extend that
form concept and this worked well to
sell the idea within HP we're extending
the form concept into a panel okay and
the the panel manager allows things like
helps you traverse between the fields if
you want to have just a simple form that
has text fields in it you can do it and
you can hit hit your return key and just
skip right through them looks like a
form that was that was the basic idea at
that level the field that urges the
interactive gadgets we see them as
objects they really are objects that's
bitmapped graphical user interface just
cries out for object
and they control the appearance of a
region take input from it they can
contain data that the program can set
and read back if it wishes and its
appearance it depends upon the state
that it's insensitive insensitive you
there's many other states that you can
put it into we provide a standard set
basically various buttons title bar
scroll bar picks map functions you're
placing or or editing them placing and
editing a text either placing it
statically or editing with single or
multi lines these are built on top of
the intrinsic layer which is an input
abstraction on top of X next event which
allows you to merge input from various
file descriptors setting timeouts and
you can get your input by either a
blocked cold you can block it unblocked
course but you can have a cold read
which is uninterpreted events coming to
you or you can ask for a hot read in
which the input model then is taking
over and it is it is where it is
interacting with the user without the
application needing to be aware so when
you're in a hot read if the user brings
up a menu and it traverses down the
hierarchy decides none I don't want that
goes over comes on another so one
finally makes an item selection the
applications not involved at any of that
until the user finally does make a
selection and then either the the
function is executed directly or the the
event gets popped back in the input
queue that says the user selected this
item out of the menu okay when we found
that a useful abstraction the okay the
message oriented interface I should talk
about we used a very regular way of
interacting programmatic interface which
is basically your the parameters are
three instance message and data and our
work with deck on the X toolkit and so
forth one of it one of the questions
that's come in on the comment the the
proposal that we put forth for the X
toolkit its new why what do you want
that and I'd like to address that we
found at first you know the previous
simple versions of x-ray were procedural
each each filled editor was represented
by a set of procedures you'd have a
cluster of them and in the next related
would have another cluster of them and
another cluster in another cluster there
were two problems with that one a panel
couldn't arbitrarily manipulate one of
these Follette udders without knowing
ahead of time what procedure it should
call to perform that function on that
fill editor it was very difficult to add
arbitrary fillers in what you wanted was
one thing to call or send a message to
it says do this operation I don't know
anything about you but just do this
operation okay and so we found it much
better to have one call with a message
and an instance to work with secondly we
found that by putting that message
oriented interface throughout the the
library there was transfer program or
learning at first there was some rough
edges where we didn't use that style and
programmers using x-ray we're making
mistakes where they were putting that
style into places where we hadn't put it
and we realized that just by putting it
in and following the programmers
intuition you get transfer of learning
and a much stronger more comfortable
easier to use programming environment
and then other advantages of that just
flow it on in that it gradually gets the
the people that were a lot of our
customers are you know are not looking
head to object-oriented programming but
by getting them in a sort of getting
used to that style we're preparing them
to phase over into object-oriented
programming okay let me quickly show you
the an overview these these are done by
hand these are not taken off the screen
this is from marketing and so forth
that's basically the visuals how they
look without these boxes these are not
that's just an artifact of the slide
this is a quick view of a panel with a
title bar
a message box here's a menu showing a
title bar it's optional cascading down
there's a keyboard equivalent ctrl C
it's very nice one to have to get
forgetting out where are we going in the
future so the current status is that
x-ray is a product it's going to be
supported by HP it has a like all
products HP we we have to extend it into
the future we want to bring it over onto
whatever standards evolve and on X and
we there is more of our plan here that
we have to put in any way we've made
commitments to our customers and so we
are what we're doing is rolling in the
the good ideas that are coming out of
our work on the X toolkit and we're
offering a migration path to our
customers onto the X toolkit when it can
finally stabilize and we want it to
stabilize as quickly as possible okay
what's coming in our in our next phase
is reading and writing of panels and so
forth
easy into files taking them back okay
then we want to use that for transition
tools to getting go off into the X
toolkit so if you've spent a lot of time
doing an application it's got bunches of
panels and message boxes and menus and
so on and so on you don't have to redo
all that and whatever standard emerges
it can be just converted over for you
okay our intent with this is to is to
continue adding functionality make it
easier and easier to use and provide a
support path on into the future at
native language support for for world
i/o that's part of an ongoing effort in
just world i/o that we're doing in
general with unix native language
support system is being contributed to X
open by Hewlett Packard language
bindings release 11 will be there in
release 11 cut buffer management called
callback functions and events intrinsic
these are both very strong architectural
capabilities that we want to have the
the
X toolkit work they were doing with Dec
makes great use of this and it solves a
lot of difficulties that you run into
and we want to to work these in and this
is part of the plan to bridge over add
more fuel editors okay we expect that
there will be field editors contributed
by other people inside HP or people
outside HP if you're programming and
you're adding you want to do your own
custom fill editor you can you can
contribute that on the source for X ray
is has been given to MIT as well as the
source for this document is also
contributed to MIT what we are we see as
needed is for the industry to work
together on the platform it's what we
call platform upon which software
applications are built and above which
different hardware engines run the
platform is has the planks in it that
allow applications and hardware to run
in a heterogeneous environment planks on
that platform are obviously the
operating system and networking user
interface when doing that the the whole
ball of wax it's at the platform level
that we need to work together to to
forge standards you want to make UNIX
successful and you want to get the
software gates opened and so I'm a
message to you is if you're a software
developer start developing today
let's get that software out there let's
get it on the market let's make money ok
ok all right that's I think that's
really all the time I have so if for any
questions maybe ok John you're you're on
next
yes I do okay let me answer a couple of
questions and then okay
okay the question is should there should
the format of the resource files be pure
ask you that are editable or should they
be some kind of binary we see that it
needs to be binary because there are
things besides ASCII data that you want
to put in there if I write a chess game
and I'm using a font a special font to
create that the chess pieces and so
forth I'm going to be able to write my
font out to the resource file
yeah we're okay that's that's it's good
but we're in the process of doing of
defining that format but what we feel is
that there are other things that you may
want to do and maybe you want to put
them in an HX format that you can
convert into binaries but at the the
moment your application runs you want to
have that resource available and it's
icons or arbitrary resources we don't
have restricted to things that have to
be converted to be used okay maybe maybe
you're sure your targets will shorter
John okay
the series the model 320 yeah that's
that's what our product is released on
is the 320 and we we work closely with
Fort Collins which is the source work
that does star base for example which is
the graphics package that we have is the
proprietary one and we're working with
them to bring that onto X and one of the
things that we want to do with the X
community's figure it how do you do you
know extend x11 and add some standard
extensions that do high-performance
graphics in a heterogeneous way excuse
me if you if you want to order it it's
it's available February 1 and the yeah
call your HP salesman but here's there's
the part number on the excerpt there yes
why did you decide not to go that way
well we
well I think I think it's question is if
you want to do a mmm some kind of
interactive gadget should you make a
call to a library or should you just
have a little little program that you
can send down and be interpreted in some
way if that's it's your question and we
see that again we're addressing current
customer needs and we found that current
customers are programming in a language
they don't want to learn yet another
language in order to do a user interface
okay it's not it's not necessary for
them to do that and when X the X server
can handle and interpret it when the X
serving becomes an interpretive server
obviously this thing can can be extended
or whatever user interface library gets
to make use of that
even though we won very very
and interrupt an FFT okay yeah it sounds
like it and it sounds like that okay
that's fine that's right that's fine I
would say that that's more of a question
for for the underlying X what what what
we are trying to do is is not revise X
we're trying to use X and put things in
there that that will will make user
interface easier on top of that okay
okay and one final comment to that -
have we been looking at other machines
we we ran our regression suite
by the way there we have a regression
suite of tests that we done for x-ray
and we validated that our port to the
micro VAX and Sun that was very easy was
little harder to get to Sun because
they're more of a Berkeley system than
in system 5 but we we were able to to
get it over and run our verification
tests on that before we contribute it to
MIT we have not compiled it up on on
about on out what a Cray or ok but ok
you've got the source so you can do that
ok thank you
[Applause]
yeah first up
okay they're pretty weird
my name is John Brewster and I'm from
Hewlett Packard also in the Corvallis
division and Frank and I work together
as a team and we've divided the job up
between the application user interface
and system user interface and I've been
working on the system user interface
problem for about eight years and I've
gotten tired of implementing window
managers so we were pretty delighted
when we ran across decks and it met our
current specifications met our current
needs and so we started doing ports one
of the things we discovered those we
have the same old problem that we're
spending a lot of our time after doing
these ports just trying to decide
whether or not we can afford to release
the product the bug rates are they
acceptable how do we know we've tested
all the functionality all of that HP has
a variety of displays CPUs input devices
operating systems and when you multiply
all that together you have a real
testing problem one of the things I'd
like to point out is I changed the title
of the talk a little bit I removed
validation and put in verification my
purpose was really to describe the
quality problem and the release problem
the knowing that you have a product
which you can sell to your customers and
that they get what they get what they
want the validation problem may be
defined to be the standardization issue
and that's really a different thought
process and one that I wasn't prepared
to talk about
speaking of which however I just came
from the press conference down the
street and I'm pleased to announce to
you folks that this is no longer an
emerging standard it is an official
Wendling standard so
very impressive bunch of folks down
there okay so now that we have a
standard now that we have this standard
you find you've got a lot of interesting
problems these are the problems that we
ran up against as implementers of X we
ported the server and we were done and
we ran X demo and we liked it
how do we know it's all really there we
also ported the client code and we said
oh yeah this stuff will just run and
seemed to but how do we know that that
was that was good stuff and as we got
through it in particular at the final
stages when 10.4 was available like one
week before product introduction and we
integrated the fixes into there I'm
going wow we're pretty nervous so these
are the problems we run up against
constantly and the ones at which we were
most interested in solving the way we've
solved it was by applying some
information that we'd gathered over the
last several years we've done some test
Suites on some different window managers
and we've learned a few things we
learned that you've got to have a
handoff test regression that you walk
away from come back the next day and
find out whether or not your system is
ready to release you cannot afford to do
monkey testing hours and hours of people
just banging on the keyboard it's not
going to cut it you have to be able to
capture a session where the guy has put
together a test plan this is what he's
going to test bla bla bla bla bla in a
way it goes now it'll regress and it's
got to be a fairly nice capture
technology you should not be forced into
doing something very artificial to
capture this session you should be able
to just use the system otherwise your
testers will rebel many times the
testing of a user interface has to be
done by naive users to really pick up on
certain details you can't always come in
here with author tests sometimes it's
non author tests sometimes you don't
have the resources to come up with
author tests so you your your people are
likely to be manual writers or other
folks there that are maybe users of the
system but not sophisticated in the test
technology so a simple session capture
has to be possible you also want to be
able to develop for those of you that
are process oriented a test plan and
then some test specs and then actually
evolve that into a test script very
mechanically and then just stand back
and watch it happen you don't
necessarily want to capture sessions and
you have to be able to modify these
things the comment that was made earlier
on on on the user interface data files
is relevant to test scripts these things
you know an 8 hour long test
you do not want to start from scratch to
create that Hummer you have got to be
able to get in there and diddle it okay
so what do you have to do to put
together such a system you have to have
resource locking you've got to be able
to have the test monitor client as it
were go out and lock the resource to do
some things there are some operations
that have to be atomic collections of
operations you have to be able to
capture images so that you can test to
find out what's going on this is a
graphical user interface and you've got
to be able to get back that graphics and
you've got to be able to capture the
input for a session capture and to be
able to synthesize that input and we've
mentioned at a very low level the point
I wanted to make there is that we want
to test all of the server as much of the
server as we possibly can we've got to
get that input down at a very low level
so that it can filter back up but then
we can get the most testing we found
that X did these two already at least
the version 10 version did the first two
things immediately so we didn't have a
problem but we had to do some
modification I was a fairly small
machete so it wasn't wasn't too drastic
the basic strategy then is that we have
a tool that we call team on for test
monitor and you typically have either a
client that you're going to be testing
or some strange little test program
that's attacking the server and then
you've got the basic server itself we
chose to go with a server that has the
team on modifications for input
synthesis in it all the time even in the
end product for a couple of reasons it's
it's good for demos but we also didn't
want to incur the open-loop cycle of
going in modifying our server after we'd
run our tests and then shipping that so
the server that we actually ship will be
capable of running these regressions
well yes and no it's our original
project plan stated that we would have
that interface understood at first
release and maybe some tools we're
pleased that we've got actually the
tools up and running in the beginning of
a suite and we're now ready to in fact
this is one of the things we're doing
here is is finding out who's interested
who what body should be involved and so
yeah we're willing to document it give
it away extended into the eleven
whatever we want to do basic usage
pattern for a user who needs to use the
system then he's got two ways to go
about doing his business assuming he's
got a test plan to work from whether or
not he's got automated tools he may
decide to sit down at the user session
one of the modes of team on capture the
input into a file so he'll use the
system he'll break into a special
command mode to do certain image
captures capture the top window capture
the mouse window capture the whole
screen whatever there are other
extensions possible into the future that
we've done on previous systems you can
capture a rectangular area on the screen
of any size to cut down on your data
space size for these tests okay you can
also develop a test specification using
any random editor that then runs through
another utility and is turned into a
special kind of test grip that has no
data so it's a it's another way to run
team on with the input being a test grip
which is the output of this guy and what
happens then is the test script is run
and the data is captured so now you turn
it from this kind of test script file
with no data into a test script file
with data now you've got your database
and you can run test monitor a second
time with a different option which will
run that data database run that test
script generating a log file I did this
I did that I did the other thing and a
failure file and the failure filed
consists of the image that it was
supposed to get and the image that it
did get and I think that's about all it
does for right now although there are
ways to get out more information like
where is the difference if you've got a
1k by 1k couple of 1k images sometimes
hard to figure out what went wrong
but some extra tools there could be done
another thing we can do is take the test
script which is the the output of the
first pass of team on and a couple of
more utilities to turn it back into a
human readable format so this thing can
be edited so this test script after it's
run through this out utility is
then a series of keystrokes a series of
timing information a series of data
sections and you can go in and extract
pieces merge test scripts change the
timing do those sorts of things and then
run it through Tran in back into a test
script now that can then be forced back
into team on we're not all that pleased
with with the usability of all of this
but at least it's a start it's it's it's
some proof that some tools can can't
exist and they can do some interesting
things okay so in summary of the actual
tools then test monitor is the primary
tool that we set out to do it does image
capture it does the test regression and
it does printing these test files are
kind of bizarre they're all compacted
strange sorts of things
teaming knows how to take those things
and print them out to you so that
they're in Nice formats for archival
purposes or whatever we did some data
compression on the images because those
images get very big sometimes into the
megabytes and a test suite can can take
20 30 40 megabytes depending on you know
what it's testing we've done some some
simple run length encoding which is fine
for window tests but for full screen
test with a lot of gray space you take
it in the teeth okay the other
interesting information here is that we
we generated a new type of event on the
image synthesis we found that we wanted
the client to run in the same
environment as he would normally run the
client under test and we found that if
we were capturing every single diddily
little event all mouse movements all
keystrokes everything that some of our
systems some of our lower cost systems
were very bogged down so we went ahead
and and compressed many of the mouse
Devan
into a new event type and that helped
our system throughput quite a bit
there's timing information in there the
timing information can be manipulated
generically also when you run tests
monitor you can say run it twice as fast
as it was originally captured or add
five seconds to every keystroke or there
are several other kinds of options so
that if you're if you are not compute
bound in other words you're not trying
to get in sync you can run things faster
and get quite a benefit out of that
there are several things we'd like to do
with it
we'd like to extend our knowledge of x11
into this test monitor technology see
what can be done there perhaps use some
of the x11 enhancements extension codes
to implement some of the things we're
not yet sure whether the x11 needs to be
extended whether the input synthesis
that's already there is sufficient or
whether we need to come out at a lower
level again the problem there is that we
want to test all of the server not just
the client to client path so it works a
little bit wrastling with that and I
think we're going to wait until we get
the x11 bits from MIT and to make that
final decision okay we are willing to
make these things available but we need
to really find out whether it's worth it
to anybody it was certainly worth it to
us to do it but we could certainly you
know submit team on and the other
technology back to MIT and place that in
the public domain as we did with x-ray
and we'd be willing to work with the
rest of the community to come up with a
good suite a good test suite it's a
massive job there's a lot of tests that
could be done we've just barely
scratched the surface we have maybe 20%
of our total tests automated this way at
the moment it's good it's great I mean
it's it's it gives you a nice good
feeling to come back the next morning
and know that at least your system is is
20% there
because a lot of times when you're just
monkey testing you just execute the same
old pass through the code time after
time okay what we have done then - to
help get this ball rolling is we've
identified an engineer and his boss
agrees that he can do this role so phone
numbers and and mail addresses because
I'm difficult to get a hold of through
the mail so any comments if you want to
be involved in generating a test suite
we're gonna start we're gonna organize
that through George
our summary is that we're very pleased
with the tools that we've got we found
them to be very useful when we did our
mr meeting we discussed the output of
these tests which is which is the thing
that we do at HP we go through an mr
meeting and discuss our quality we found
that not only was it interesting for us
as X implementers but that application
vendors ought to be interested in this
sort of technology also let's say Alice
gets their port running and they've some
new whiz-bang server comes on the scene
how do we know that Alice can really
support that server as as a display
server well if they've got a test suite
then for themselves they can just hook
up the new server run the test suite and
they know that they can support that
server so it's it's a good deal for
application vendors also great demos you
don't have to have anybody sitting there
punching the wrong key or anything like
that you can just stand back
you've got your option of whether or not
to lock the keyboard out while the test
is going so you could have a locked
keyboard just stand back and watch the
menus come and go and the windows slide
around and in summary we would like to
keep working on this technology and we'd
love to get some help questions yes
okay the question is when you're doing
demos can you get in and out of this
demo mode easily no not right now at the
moment it could be done it's all under
control of test team on but at the
moment it just runs to completion so are
there any tools and how do you debug
your test run how do you know you know
how can you deal with that one of the
things we've got in the human readable
formats is we've got comments which
appear in the log file so I got here and
this happened I got there and this
happened and matching that and the bad
images file give you a pretty good feel
for where you are and what went wrong I
think there's more work to be done there
but at least we're not totally in the
dark going hey I just failed
so perhaps an interactive tool to allow
you to create the thing interactively
not just simple capture and not just
simple post-processing maybe something
more in between it's a good idea yes
sure yeah the problem here is different
different resolutions and different
color depths it turns out will throw off
your image capture a lot of times what
you have to do on a different screen is
run team on with another mode that
captures an original set of images and
actually go through them by eye and make
sure they're right sometimes if the
screens are that far off you have to do
that the other problem you run into when
we're talking about different platform
architectures is the CPU intensive
applications will take more or less time
to execute and you can out run your test
monitor the test motor could say capture
the screen and the application hasn't
come up with an answer yet failure boom
you're dead you can rerun those kinds of
things and and diddle those also so
sometimes you can't just stand back and
assume it's going to work you have to go
in and diddle it we haven't ever found a
way out of that it's not really a team
on problem as much as it is yeah you
there are some things you can do there
are some things you could do to help it
out for instance you never read the
whole screen don't do it bad idea you
also run your tests from a dedicated
directory with all the default files
font specifications and everything under
your control so that you do your you do
window captures with fonts that you have
controlled you do those sorts of things
and you've got a very high a better
chance of success if you're just doing
fullscreen image captures then when you
go from hardware to hardware you will
have a problem yes
yes no no real performance measuring we
measure the capture sequence or you can
specify the time in order to do the
match but all it really does is after
generating some keystrokes it'll wait a
certain amount of time capture the image
so it won't find out how fast it took
the program to generate that image was
there's no real performance monitoring
tools I'd be an interesting study also
one one extra detail on that if an image
match fails we do assume that there may
be a computation problem wait a few
seconds try again I think we do that
maybe five times so that to try to help
that situation but yes
No
we use the standard event header stuff
specified a new event type and then just
use the data specific stuff to cram a
bunch of it could well be no actually we
didn't do anything with X live we
generated our own little library that we
linked in before X 11
no no let's go back to the this diagram
the client under test which maybe the
application doesn't see compound events
it's only the test monitor that sees
compound events yes
yeah we've experimented with that on
different window systems and there's
there's some work that can be done there
synchronizing this guy with one
application is bad enough
synchronizing him with a whole lot of
applications can get really sticky at
the moment what you have to do is you
specify a long enough wait time the
chaplains will be done the other thing
we have done we have found is that we
run our our tests from scripts which
then sleep a jillion in between
themselves and the capture sequence that
runs this thing is that it runs this
test the test goes to sleep now team on
comes in captures the image after that
point it does something like a control C
or whatever to kill off one test and go
into the next so you can do some
cleverness by by killing your
application from your team ensuite or
controlling it via keystrokes from your
team ensuite and yet still have these
applications unaware of what's going on
so there's some funny business you can
do but we don't have any formalism yet
no it was a cooperative test creation
state where the user said I'm gonna run
setup things with some scripts and some
other synchronization because most
applications have got a pause or a way
to stick around or you know there's
there's a lot of different kinds of
things you can take advantage of and you
can synchronize those by encoding into
your test suite some of those commands
to these applications yes
what kind of problems did we in fact
find with this kind of technology they
come in in two classes mainly we found
that as we went through our design cycle
an implementation cycle we would make
changes in particular we had a hard time
with our clipping algorithms the X line
drawing device-dependent routine can get
quite large in fact it blew up our
complexity analyzer and we found that as
we did 'old that and made changes to it
that it did break our server in ways
that we may not have found and so we did
pick up some of that X ray used it
effectively to get at the different
screens so that there their team is a
very small team of air and and very
highly productive and they couldn't
afford to sit down and watch so they
didn't actually find that many bugs
where they gained was in not having to
watch the screen so they were more
productive as opposed to actually
finding bugs and that's sort of an
alternate benefit so our team found some
bugs and they got a little extra
productive
you